hello everyone this is rick of shaw and
this talk is on a spectral approach to
polytope diameter
this talk will have three main parts the
first is an introduction to the problem
in a little bit of history the second
will be about results from spectrograph
theory and the third will be how to use
those results from spectrograph theory
in the context of this problem using
some facts from uh convex geometry
so let's go to the next slide
so the first thing to note is just what
a polytope is a polytope is the set of
points satisfying a collection of linear
inequalities ax less than b entry wise
for our purposes
b will be always be a positive vector
that way zero is in the interior of this
polytope and given any polytope you can
always translate it so that this is
indeed the case
define a point on the surface of this
polytope to be a vertex if d of the
constraints of the polytope are tight at
that point
and a line segment similarly has d minus
one constraints tight uh at those points
so in this picture here we have drawn uh
dots for the vertices and lines for the
edges denoting the vertices and edges of
the cube which is of course a polytope
the vertices and edges of the polytope
uh become the vertices and edges of a
graph called the one skeleton this graph
is always connected and the problem that
we are dealing with is how to how to
bound its diameter
so what is the largest possible diameter
of a graph in terms of m the number of
constraints indeed the ambient dimension
this problem is motivated by linear
program linear programming where
the potential solutions are the vertices
of some polytope and various algorithms
will try to find the optimal uh vertex
starting from an arbitrary vertex by
jumping between adjacent vertices so in
this picture here i have a diagram of a
polytope and the red path denotes the
path that an algorithm might take to the
optimal vertex
so a trivial bound is just bounded bound
the diameter is bounded by the total
number of vertices which is m choose d
but the goal is to do much better the
conjecture from the 1950s is that the
diameter of this graph is always less
than m minus d so the number of
constraints minus the ambient dimension
uh it turns out this conjecture is false
but there's a relaxation which we which
we study
but one of the first pieces of or large
pieces of progress and still today the
best piece of progress in the general in
the general case toward this conjecture
is
that the diameter is upper bounded by m
minus d to the log d
so it's significantly better than the m
choose d
found on the number of vertices
but it's still a long way to go from
from the hirsch conjecture and indeed
like i mentioned just now the
hersch conjecture itself turns out to be
false
in particular a construction due to
santos of these polytopes called
spindles uh show that the diameter has
to be at least
at least m in fact
so the relax the relaxed conjecture or
the updated conjecture is that the
diameter is just some polynomial in m
and d
uh and we can still hope that this is
true there are no lower bounds or
there's nothing disproving this
conjecture yet
uh but similarly there hasn't been a
tremendous progress in the general case
so instead um
uh instead we introduce a new parameter
uh or or
there's a parameter that the literature
has introduced uh
to in order to make progress and that
parameter is the maximum determinant of
any sub matrix of the constraint matrix
a
um
in in particular the goal now is to
bound the diameter in terms not just of
m and d but also delta this max den
so two of the important results in this
area are one if the max state is one in
other words this constraint matrix a is
unimodular then the diameter is indeed
less than some polynomial in m d
and for larger delta there's a there's a
more recent results which shows that the
diameter is at most o of d cubed times
delta squared
so this work seeks to make an
improvement or does make an improvement
where the d
d cubed parameter is improved to a log m
delta
or improved in some setting of these
parameters
so that is what this talk will be about
now on to spectrograph theory this is
the first set of ingredients which are
key to the results in the paper
first i'm going to define this
generalized adjacency matrix which is
similar to adjacent in a regular
adjacency matrix except we allow the off
diagonal entries to be anything as
opposed to simply one
actually we require that they that they
be positive so
sij is only non-zero if i j is an edge
of g and that and that and that value is
is actually going to be uh positive
and the result about them
is that if we have a spectral gap so
there's a
so in other words the smallest sorry the
largest eigenvalue of sa is one plus
gamma for some small parameter gamma
and the rest of the eigenvalues are in
the interval minus one to one then we
say that this matrix s has a spectral
gap of gamma
and the diameter is upper bounded by log
of the number of vertices
plus log of 1 over the smallest entry of
the eigenvector
corresponding to the top eigenvalue
divided by square root of gamma
so the larger the spectral gap the
better bound on diameter one achieves
in a picture i have drawn a little
diagram of where all the eigenvalues are
so the lambda n through lambda two are
all in the interval minus one's one and
the top eigenvalue is
gamma larger than the rest of them
so a proof of the theorem is quite
straightforward
first consider raising this generalized
adjacency matrix to the kth power
and note that because s is a symmetric
matrix we can decompose it
into a spectral decomposition
and we will write this with its top
eigenvalue separated out from the
remaining eigenvalues
and from this expression uh we can bound
each entry of this matrix as to the k
uh lower bound or rather uh quite simply
by bounding each term independently so
the first term is at least one plus
gamma raised to the k
times the smallest entry in that in v1
squared
then minus the an upper bound on the
absolute values of the remaining terms
so each of these other
lambdas are at most one and v i v
vt is each entry there is also upper
bounded uh by one
so rearranging this inequality and
taking k large enough means that every
entry in s the k will be positive
but the entries in s the k can only be
non nonzero whenever there is a path
from i to j
so because each entry next to the k is
positive we know that there is a
that there is an upper bound of a k on
the diameter of the graph
but of course in the sound we see that
uh
there's a dependence on a gamma as
opposed to root gamma and on k
and the way to fix this and introduce
the root gamma is to replace raising s
to the ks power directly by applying the
degree to a chebychev polynomial to
2f
so these polynomials are bounded by one
on the an absolute value on the interval
minus one to one and they also grow
really quickly outside that interval
and they grow sufficiently quickly that
we only need k to be
have a dependence on root gamma as
opposed to gamma
okay
so that's the theorem from spectrograph
three which which uh we require for our
main result
and now we need to know how to apply it
to this problem
so remember the two parameters that
we're going to be working our way
towards are one is a
a
spectral gap and two a lower bound on
the minimum entry in the eigenvector
so but in order to do all that we need
to first construct a uh a generalized
adjacency matrix right we know what the
adjacency matrix is but we need to know
what weights do we apply on each of the
edges such that we end up with those two
desirable properties a spectral gap and
a
sufficiently large smallest entry in an
eigenvector
so to do that we're going to introduce
the idea of the polar of a
polytope so first of all uh think of a
polytope uh ax less than b as as the
constraints are
think of the rows of this matrix a as
the individual constraints
uh if there are m of them then they're m
facets and n vertices where n could be
quite large
uh but these rows
we can instead of taking them to be the
constraints
uh we can take those we can take them
directly normalize them appropriately
and then take their convex hull and that
will also produce a convex set
and this convex set is called the polar
of p
and the m facets of the original
correspond directly to the vertices of
the polar which can be seen just by the
definition these constraints become the
points that we're taking the convex hull
of
but furthermore the n vertices of the
original polytope become the facets of
the polar
and this is that fact is less obvious to
see but here we've drawn an example if a
cube is the original original polytope
its polar will be the octahedron so the
uh six
facets or faces of the cube become the
sixth vertices of the octahedron
and the eight vertices of the cube
become the eight facets of the
octahedron
so the graph which corresponds to edges
and vertices in the original
becomes a graph in the polar where the
nodes in the graph are the facets
and the edges
in the graph are the intersection
between two adjacent facets so whenever
two facets have a non-trivial
intersection then
that produces an edge in the graph so
it's the facet incidence graph
of the polar
so the n verses the original become n
facets in the polar and we want to bound
the diameter of the facet incident graph
of the pole
now the key idea here is that the polar
itself is some polytope
so in other words it could be written in
in the form mx less than c for some
matrix matrix m and a positive vector c
in some neighborhood of that vector c
think of the function which sends that
vector c to the volume of the pole of
that polytope
so we've introduced this parameter c
which
correctly parameterizes uh the space of
polars
and we're now considering the
this function which computes its volume
the first claim that we make is that the
hessian of v
is indeed the a a generalized adjacency
matrix of the graph
and it will be um or a a scaling of it
in a shifting of it will be the one
which we apply uh the theorem to from
the previous section
and the second claim is that this
hessian has exactly one positive
eigenvalue and this will help us get a
spectral gap
but first let's prove claim one
and we'll just sort of do a proof by
picture here
so think of the derivative of this
volume with respect to one of those
slack variables say ci
and we claim it's equal to the area of
fi
and to see that look at this little
diagram written on the right hand side
of the of the pit of the slide here
as you change the eye by some small
amount
the amount of volume that's added to
the polytope is this little as that
little rectangular region
where the length of the rectangle is fi
so the the derivative of v with respect
to ci is just that area
now if we were to take the derivative of
this of this function with respect to a
different slack variable say cj
then we want to know how quickly does
the uh does the size of one facet change
as you change the slack variable
corresponding to a different facet
and there you can see that that value
will only be non-zero if the two facets
intersect
if the two facets don't intersect then
changing c1 will not is not going to
affect the area of uh
of ci is not going to affect the area of
fj for some different uh from some
different j
so this value is only non-zero indeed is
only nonzero it's the two fastest
intersect and furthermore we can exactly
compute what this what what the the
magnitude of the effect is and it's just
the cos the cosecant between the angle
of the vectors which are normal to the
two facets
okay so now let's look at claim two
which is that the session has exactly
one positive eigenvalue
and this is actually an instance of a
more general fact
uh about log concave functions so the
first claim is that the function which
maps c to log of the volume is a concave
function
and as a consequence the hessian is a
negative semi-definite matrix
and
then the hessian of the volume has
exactly one positive eigenvalue
now these aren't trivial facts to prove
but they're they're known previously and
we've for this talk uh just take them to
be a uh to be a black box um but this is
a general fact that it works for
any kind of
log concave function
so
this fact on the previous slide here
just says that there's one positive
eigenvalue but it doesn't say how large
it is
and we actually want it to be quite
large compared to the other eigenvalues
in order to get a sufficiently large
spectral gap
and
that will be done by noting that hessian
is of this particular form
of
minus the laplacian plus a strictly
positive diagonal entry a diagonal
matrix
so when you compute the individual
entries the off and diagonal entries
have these dependents on cosecant it
turns out the diagonal entries have a
dependence on on tangent in some uh over
all facets in um
or all adjacent facets
so the entries in the diagonal are all
smaller than they would need to be in
order or all smaller than the sum of the
entries
of the other entries in that particular
row
so
the hessian is sort of like a laplacian
except all the diagonal entries are
wrong and they're all wrong in the same
direction
so we can express the hessian as minus
the laplacian plus a strictly positive
diagonal matrix
so multiplying the left and right hand
side by d to the one-half
we get by sylvester's law that the
left-hand side has exactly one positive
eigenvalue
and the right-hand side is a negative
semi-definite matrix because recall that
laplacians are positive semi-definite
plus the identity matrix
and indeed
both sides of this equation has
has an eigenvalue at exactly one and
that's because the laplacian has a null
space so it's pretty
clear how to construct the corresponding
eigenvector on the right hand side just
take v to be the square root of all the
diagonal entries in d
and then all the other eigenvalues are
negative or
or zero so they're all non-positive
so we would like to do a shift a scale
and shift all these eigenvalues
so such that lambda 2 through lambda n
all lie in the interval minus 1 to 1 as
opposed to
negative infinity to zero
and that way that and then the shift it
up so that the top eigenvalue is at one
plus some parameter gamma as opposed to
being exactly at one
so we can do that by just lower bounding
the eigenvalue is far away from zero
using ker score and circle theorem but
uh when you work out what all those
things are using a little bit of linear
algebra and some trigonometric
inequalities
uh you can find that this gamma
parameter when you scale everything up
is
the sine squared of the smallest
angle between facets of the polar
and the angle between facets of the
polar what i mean is the angle between
their normal vectors
so with this result we can apply the
theorem
uh
the bound on the diameter using the the
theorem that used chebychev polynomials
in the proof
and we also know exactly what v min is
remember we said uh just on the previous
slide that v is equal to the square
roots of the diagonal entries of d
uh so
we can convert all those bounds into
bounds using the angles between adjacent
facets and also use the fact that
and also bounds on the size of the
entries in a
and that becomes the uh desired bound at
the end
if one likes one could instead get a
bound not in terms of this max debt
squared but instead in terms of the
largest entry in a and also the smallest
angle between uh adjacent facets uh but
just to make comparison with other
results in the literature
more straightforward we express it here
in in terms of the delta squared
okay so as a summary of what happened
here we started with the fact that the
log of the volume of the polar of a
given polytope is a concave function
as a as a consequence the hessian of
that function has exactly one positive
eigenvalue
which implies that uh you are using
using then a relationship with a
laplacian matrix we can show that that
matrix has a sufficiently large spectral
gap such that when we apply
a theorem
from spectral graph theory that you we
arrive at the fact that the graph has
small diameter
okay
that's not summary of uh these results
and some open questions uh in the future
are
one is can we prove the polynomial horse
conjecture for random polytopes um
so we believe the general polynomial
herc conjecture is still completely open
and
second can we analyze what happens for a
random walk on the graph so this was
analyzing sort of the
the length of an optimal walk
but what happens for a random walk
and the third question is can we use
some higher hard riemann relations uh
for polytopes so the fact that the
hessian has exactly one positive
eigenvalue is a dream on relation but
there's a question as to whether a kind
of highly speculative idea as to whether
the higher relations could do something
as well
um that's it for the talk i appreciate
you all uh tuning in and feel free to
email us if you have any questions or
uh thoughts on these open questions
and thank you and have a great
conference